foreign
let's kick this uh first audit and risk
committee meeting underway as Stuart is
an apology
um I have taken upon myself to
um just cheer this uh until he's back
and we'll delay the the election of the
the deputy until then unless there is a
burning desire around the table to cheer
this meeting for this
once nope cool
um so I'll I'll share it and then next
time Stuart will be up here and um he
can make the the election for Deputy so
do have a think about whether you want
to take that home
first up on the agenda
[Music]
well we will have obviously there's an
apology there from Stuart and I believe
Joe stringers on this committee too
so apologies from both of them as well
uh
uh the apologies aren't on the agenda do
we need to pass it as a motion
ideally yeah yeah could I please get a
move for that motion
John Garden and a seconder
councilor Rich mcphail all those in
favor of police AI
and against the motion is carried
first up the quarterly treasury reports
did Lorne want to speak to this at all
this one hopefully
um but for new council members this is a
regular report on air ordered and risk
supplied To Us by Bancorp Bank or para
treasury advisors and they advise us on
the the types of debt we want to take
and how long for and try to get us the
be Steeler they can at the time
so the report itself is more for
information for counselors what it shows
is the movement in our debt from from
previous periods it shows a current
weighted average cost Capital which is
our current interest rate that's one of
the things that has moved significantly
from December 2021 to 2022 it has gone
from an average of three percent up to
3.98 which is consistent with what we're
seeing in the economy at the moment with
with interest rates
um so there's been quite a bit of
movement since the December report
the we have
the the teams have been undertaking a
lot of their projects the projects are
all catching up to where we had
anticipated them being in the last 12 to
18 months and we've had taken on quite a
significant amount of borrowing
um but the projects that are currently
underway that aspiring is used for
things like the Elizabeth Street
separation the Matilda water treatment
plant
dislodging project the library next door
Motorway Center so these are all
projects that have all hit at the same
time and we are looking to being
forecasting towards their 50 million
debt budget at 30th of June 2023 so I'm
forecasting that now
but happy to take some questions and
hopefully miles will pop in to talk to
anything that we need to
yeah he did accept he's um he was saying
that he was having some technology
issues out of a hotel in Te kuiti sorry
he may
but I'm happy to take some questions if
there's any questions here
with the debt increase and then and the
interest increased it probably puts
about 900 000 more into your budget
doesn't it all right for next year at
may do um so what I want to remember is
that a lot of the step we had budgeted
to take out earlier so we've actually uh
had some savings from interest on on
those deaths that we would have taken
out in previous years that haven't been
taken out so you'll see more of it with
the annual plan
the annual plan will give us the better
indication and we're hoping to have that
to councilors in the near future
any further questions
I might move on to the next point I'm
just so we can Circle back just in case
um he jumps on yeah
oh
so we'll move on to uh number two number
three number two uh the authority to
upgrade the project update
did we have any comment from law now on
that one
uh thank you you're worshiping through
also through the chair because we're in
a committee
um this is actually a really good news
project for for the council uh the
authority upgrade project today you'll
notice that I have tabled a um
circulated and updated report or an
updated a couple of pages on how a
testing has gone so this was uh up to
date as of Saturday
um on the whole um and again we've had
invited Alan radbone who's been project
managing that for us
um
to to a joined by Zoom to answer
questions for the counselors but this is
this is a good news project the project
has run really smoothly there's been a
lot of work done pre a pre the testing
stage so a data was cleansed in October
November last year it was came out
looking really good there's only a few
things to tidy up it's been a lot of
work setting up servers and test
environments
um Ellen has been very impressed with
the progress that we have made again
we're a small organization with limited
resources so Alan has has project
manager these upgrades for numerous
councils across Australia in New Zealand
and he was really impressed with the
dedication and the and the effort that
the team have put in he's also surprised
with how many how few issues we've had
but the upgrade this version of the
upgrade has been out for a couple of
years so civica has done a lot of work
and ironing arts on the bugs um so yeah
we're really comfortable with how it's
gone we have given the go live push the
button to go live on the 3rd of March
so yeah happy to take some questions of
the specific questions that counselors
counselors have
just wanted to say a big congratulations
to the staff on on getting it over the
line I know it's been a massive project
and
fingers crossed for going live
because um having worked in live
environments I know that it's always a
time to hold your breath
but that it's fantastic and great to see
that that upgrade um completed do we
have any questions for from councils
no questions
no could I get a movie that information
that report will be received
uh Council mcfail seconded by councilor
heisted I will put the motion all those
in favor please say aye and against
motion is carried
onto the three Waters quarterly level of
service reports
uh
Aaron did you have any comments on this
report
thank you to you
um I just want to highlight the uh the
one
flooding event
um that was outside of our response
times that was during the heavy
downpours that we received a couple of
months back
um
the whole team was out responding to
that so sort of pushed us over the
the sort of Ledger on that one but yeah
all in all we're trekking really well
thank you for that and were there any
questions for for Aaron from councils
around the table
councilor read
thank you chair
um Aaron just it's not a question it's
just a a message passed on from a
retailer who was severely affected and
by the time it was number two or three
she actually said to me how wonderful
the three Waters boys were in helping
and you know went above and beyond so
it's really nice to see that people
recognize the hard work that you all did
thank you
sorry I guess I just misunderstood a bit
there Aaron what was the reason for the
the long response time was that just
because there was so so many staff
responding that I sorry I just a little
more cavification be fantastic yes thank
you cheer
um so during that event
um it's not just as simple as showing up
and then walking away to the next one
um those events were pumping out
people's basements
um sandbagging and all that so there was
no available staff to get on with the
um response time that's needed of 60
Minutes
um we were 14 minutes over which all in
all in an event like that I don't
think's
um too bad I think that actual one that
tipped us over was about 10 o'clock at
night so
um I've always done a superb job
I think that yeah that clears it up a
lot um hard to respond to such an event
in 60 minutes when there's there's so
much work to be done
um
and I'd imagine that was the the event
the Earth street one that did quite a
bit of was it that one
yeah but it's correct yeah yeah cool
um
and I think they're yeah
they had a lot of community interest for
sure so thank you for your response on
that one
do we have any further questions
comments
no we will move on to uh we will is
there a mover for receiving that report
uh councilor Reed secondary Council
guard iron I will put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
and against the motionless carried
health and safety reports
did Nikki want to speak to that at all
there we go that's all right so just a
for new councilors we try to keep the
health and safety report under four key
pillars so that it's consistent and you
know what you're looking at under
building capability of a paper which is
usually a training risk management what
might hurt us relationship Health how
we're developing our relationships both
internally and externally with the wider
community and our own staff and then an
opportunity to positively educate urine
areas that we wish to have note of or
anything that you should be aware of
that's changing legislatively and I
guess really the only point at this
point in time is the recommendation at
the end around the critical risk program
and just needing to start to look at how
we're going to implement it but that's
really all I had comments that I had to
say on that so if anybody has any
questions I'm happy to take them
thanks for that Nikki uh did we have any
questions or comments from councils
around the table
Council house did you thank you through
the chair Nikki so there's critical uh
risk program
um what's the timetable on there
so it has some funding that may need to
come with it which has been decorative
prices so I guess
um at the council wishes to move forward
with that within we could probably get
that up in the first stage probably in
the next three or four months because it
will take quite a period of time it will
be have to be staged but we could
probably start in the next two or three
months if we
put our mind to it and had the resource
so just carry on if you had the funding
you do have the resource one yes we have
some resource that we could put into oh
they have to be externally the amount of
um expertise in order to set the program
up would need to be is beyond our
capability and it's the foundation and
it also involves quite a considerable
consultation progress process with the
council and management in order to
identify the correct critical risks and
then how we would Implement them so it
is a release at once we've got the
program in place all those three stages
or components then we can manage it
ourselves in the house
thank you that council is going to ask
it for this question as well so glad it
was asked uh do we have any other
questions
no oh there's one burning there we go
probably not a question but to change
the recommendation I guess we should
consider that body of work at the annual
planning process
as part of your budgeting or
I'd like to move the recommendation and
add that the critical risk program
because it was part of the annual plan
[Music]
thank you the basis we're not compliant
with the X so we can't really avoid
doing this
thank you do I have a second or for that
uh councilor Reed
yep
uh yes so that we'll do the full uh of
the move is happy with that the full
recommendation with that note added yeah
uh do we have any further questions
I will put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried we're
just gonna have a two minute
intermission we're just having technical
difficulties so we're going to have Ben
come down and try and fix them so just a
two minute pause thanks guys
can you hear us up there Michael
perfect are we all ready to kick back
into it
cool
uh after you did you want to speak is
that all right or answer questions or
just be involved
okay
brilliant
okay did we want to Circle back to point
one lornay
yeah uh
so I thought it was Miles talking so in
my bed yeah
don't you don't need but he has got the
link
okay Carry On okay so we're at number
five then we're all we're all clear so
the it report um did Andrew want to
speak to the it report at all
um yeah
any any further comment on the report
um just one thing I would be interested
uh here is um
what would be useful for the audit and
risk committee to have in terms of
reporting on it and particularly aware
that cyber security
that's about as technical as it gets
but really it's understanding what would
actually be useful to you guys
and open to suggestions with a with an
hour or later
thank you for that Andrew did we have
any questions around the table
for Andrew on this report
I guess an answer to your question
Andrew it might be a discussion that we
get into and some of that in committee
stuff with the the audit report
um because there is some some stuff on
there that we might um have a discussion
about and get back to you on on that
some of the comments on there um
no further questions or any questions in
that report uh Council husted
thanks uh Mr chairman so through you to
Andrew I guess my response would be in
the opening committee would be obviously
as it manager any key risks you see that
this committee should be aware of
um that are you know keeping you awake
at night should be things that we
brought to our attention
we're probably speaking yes
um and and cyber security has to be the
number one
we've got lots of other things down the
threat list from that in terms of
resilience data quality dig Integrity
um
and all the way down to to the human
factors side in terms of Staff training
and and capability
but cyber security is the number one
because it's the one that will will come
out of left field if we
yeah even if we're watching referral
it's still probably feel
so so how are we as as members and an
organization
performing in terms of email a text Etc
have we had a recent test or is it
upcoming
um
the uh
the last trainium we bought in
crowdstrike
as as a way of detecting intrusions into
our platforms and I think as we talked
about then
um
to do a 24-hour
monitoring on our platforms and be able
to respond immediately when there are if
there were to be intrusions it's
something we couldn't do out of our own
internal staff resources which is why we
ended up with with crowdstrike
um
and
crowdstrike is rolled out is working
well
and to the best of our knowledge is
protecting all of our servers all of our
desktops environments
um
emails a little bit different
it's uh it's it's a little bit more
active and
I think it's sitting that report
we have
um a lot of malware comes through a lot
of spam comes through but the trickiest
ones are things like impersonation
attacks and
we pick up
a dozen of those a week
um
but it's again it's the human factors of
people being aware that one might get
through so so cyber security overall is
one that keeps us awake at night
um
in terms of of
risks to the organization
we already or we we also have a number
of other Platforms in place to help us
manage those risks
but it's always the how do we balance
out the working in the business on our
business as usual
and how do we work on the business and
have chance to go back and look at what
we're doing
and and those are things that once we
get our Authority upgrade out of the way
and now that we've got some Protections
in place with the likes of crowdstrike
I think the second half of this year is
is going to see quite a lot of that
working on the business pieces
um
we had some issues
uh last year last year
around our Network resilience and
in particular it's called carrier
diversity
so
even though we've got for example sales
cellular redundancy
as well as fiber ultimately they're
joined back up onto the same piece of
fiber and the chorus Network
um so so a physical redundancy physical
resilience
in this case similar to the likes of of
Gisborne
we have to find completely separate
carriers
and I believe that in in gisborne's case
they lost all their fiber they lost all
the microwave links as well
and starlink was the only way of of
having any contact out of the region
um for for reasonable volume
um so that's something that we're
probably looking at as well
so yeah we're not going to know until we
know and that that's
yeah we can
put as much in place as we can but we
can't one
ultimately
thanks there Andrew and yeah nature of
it I was having to react on the go
did uh can I have a are there any
further questions
no could I please have a mover that the
information be received
councilor Dixon in a seconder uh
councilman Paul mcfail oh sorry one more
ah apologies uh Club is there another
mover so it will make the Mover Paul
mcfail and a seconder
uh counselor Reed all those in favor
please say aye
and against
the motion is carried now we'll go back
to point number one
um
get down
foreign
so for those for those new councilors
this is Miles O'Connor miles is our
treasury advisor from Bancorp um miles I
have rushed over over the report lightly
but if there's anything that you would
like to add or that the councils would
like to ask you I'll I'll hand over to
you
thank you very much for that Miles uh
very informative do we have any
questions four miles
uh councilor husted
you're just through your chair just
miles on page 30 you've given us the
gorgeous Council interest rate
projection I think it'll be useful for
for new members to understand the
assumptions that that drive that that
time here page 30 um your page 18. of
the second report
foreign
no we'd love to hear an update
um yes it's it's over 18.8 million so
depending on what we negotiate with them
on the stranded debt on debt that has
got corporate good will depend but at
the moment somewhere upwards of over
18.8 million is three Waters debt
so obviously
foreign
all the different projects over the
various years and the debt taken out in
the year and it's assigned attuned
multiple projects in a dead tranche so
there's no one tranche of debt that's
been taken out specifically for specific
projects it's it's spread across the
various projects at the time
and just I I guess another note if we
was to that underground War option as
well that would be added to that 18 year
which means it would put us in that 20
bracket but if we're allowed up to well
if they're being lenient then we should
hopefully still fall within that which
would be grand
do we have any further questions that
were some fantastic information thanks
for that Miles
brilliant we will move on I think we're
at point six
uh oh we didn't move the motion wait uh
could I please have a mover that that
report be received
that is number one
uh councilor guardian and seconder
uh Michael Chamberlain
uh I will put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
and against
the motion is carried
on to number six risk pool update on
winding up uh Lorna did you want to
speak to that report
uh thank you Mr chair this is a more of
just an information for counselors and I
know the chief executive has got more
history behind this one than I do but
effectively it was a poll that was set
up many years ago particularly around
Leakey homes and apart from one case
that's still outstanding and they're
working through they're ready to to wind
up the pool and at that point there'll
be a
um I guess a decision made on what the
final call is of any on on councils that
were a member of that thrust pool so
it's for information purposes and
see if there's anything else that the
chief executive would like to add
three worship not really think uh Lorna
is summed it up well it's just we're
going through a
uh the long lonely match to an rip
status for the scheme
thanks for that uh what were there any
questions around this report